musulmans de france est une vaste
fresque qui va de 1914 avec les premiers
tirailleurs jusqu'en 2007 avec les
discriminations et l'intégration
nous étions des beurs nous étions les
arabes les racailles et au final la
chose qui ne disparaîtra pas c'est que
nous resterons les musulmans à travers
l'histoire de ses cinq millions de
musulmans
c'est un autre regard sur l'histoire de
france qui nous est proposé nous
musulmans de france première partie
samedi à 22h sur public sénat
bonjour à tous suite du projet de loi
sur la réforme des retraites
les discussions ont repris ce matin
l'article 8 qui porte sur la retraite
des fonctionnaires et ces discussions se
poursuivent dans un climat explosif
tout d'abord par le contexte la
mobilisation syndicale se poursuit une
nouvelle journée de manifestations est
prévue mardi prochain
puis les jeunes sont venus grossir les
rangs de la contestation ils ont été
rejoints aujourd'hui par les routiers et
la prévision en carburant est toujours
très perturbé par les grèves dans
l'hémicycle aussi les débats ont été
hier très vif ils ont été marqués par
des débats enflammés sur l'arrivée des
jeunes dans les manifestations
et puis la séance a aussi été marquée
par un incident hier une erreur de vote
d'un sénateur centriste qui a entraîné
le rejet de l'article 4 de la réforme
tout de suite donc direction les
mystiques pour la suite des débats sur
la réforme des retraites est un peu plus
large que la question des militaires
puisqu'il porte sur les catégorie
sédentaire en général mais cela dit
c'est vrai monsieur le président fischer
que l'on peut en parler si vous voulez
là mais je propose de réserver les
réponses sur les militaires aux articles
qui seront plus spécifiquement consacré
si vous le voulez bien merci
explications de vote madame david oui
simplement pour ajouter à ce que disait
monsieur guy fischer et pour rappeler
que si nous sommes nous attacher à cet
article c'est parce que évidemment là
encore vous fait passer avant toute
chose le
la partie comptable de cette de cette
réforme et j'ai bien entendu notre
collègue
j'ai bien entendu notre collègue est
effectivement ce que nous dénonçons nous
c'est que vous n'avez qu'une vision
comptable dans cette réforme du premier
au dernier article vous n'avez qu'une
vision comptable et pour réponse
comptable vous n'apportez qu'une une
réponse qui va prendre 85 % de la somme
nécessaire dans la poche des
travailleurs alors que vous allez
épargné le capital vous ne nous avez pas
bien écouté mon cher collègue mais s'il
ya nécessité
je peux recommencer à vous expliquer que
nous avons des propositions différentes
de financement de finances nouvelle pour
pouvoir alimenter notre système de
retraite par répartition
nous avons de ce côté-ci de l'hémicycle
plein de propositions sauf que ces
propositions là évidemment vous ne
voulez pas en entendre parler
donc nous n'avons pas nous un reproche à
vous faire du fait que vous ne voyez que
la vision que vous voyez la vision
comptable
et pas humaine ce que nous nous voulons
vous dire mes chers collègues c'est que
il y a une autre manière de voir la
comptabilité de cette réforme
évidemment que nous sommes tous
redevables de l'argent de l'état puisque
au final ce sont l'ensemble des
citoyennes et des citoyens qui payent
des impôts qui alimente des caisses de
l'état ce que nous nous vous reproche on
sait que vous prenez toujours dans les
poches des mêmes pour alimenter vos
réformes c'est là où nous la vision
comptable est complètement différente de
la vôtre nous nous avons en plus une
vision beaucoup plus comment dire
égalitaire et de justice sociale nous
voulons faire payer tout le monde et
chacun au niveau de ses moyens pour que
chacun puisse ensuite bénéficié selon
ses besoins
c'est là la différence fondamentale
entre vous et nous mais si besoin est
mon cher collègue nous pouvons
recommencer à vous l'expliquer merci
chers collègues pas d'autres demandes
d'explications de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent que ce qui est bon que ceux
qui souhaitent adopter cet amendement
veut bien levé la main
de chez moi
que ceux qui sont contre veuille bien
levé la main il n'est pas adopté ils ne
sont pas adoptées nous passons à
l'amendement 783 monsieur verra où
présenter peut-être en même temps le 83
84 85
ce sont les amendements de conséquence
je crois merci monsieur le président
présente le 783 et monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues
en avril dernier le ministre des armées
déclaré je cite le système de retraites
des militaires de carrière doit être
maintenu et il précisait que si le
projet de loi gouvernemental était
appelée a concerné les militaires les
mesures apportées aux régimes de
retraite des militaires ne seraient que
marginale
cela n'est d'ailleurs pas sans rappeler
les promesses non suivies d'effet du
ministre de l'intérieur en direction des
agents de la police nationale 4 car quoi
qu'en dise le ministre des armées les
conséquences pour les militaires sont
loin d'être marginal et si le ministre
reconnaît que l'allongement de la durée
de cotisation et le report de deux ans
de l'âge permettant aux généraux de
bénéficier d'une retraite sans décompte
pourraient avoir des incidences sur la
carrière de l'ensemble des militaires
pourquoi donc ne pas en tirer les
conséquences pourquoi ne pas dire
clairement que tous secteurs confondus
le report de l'âge limite de départ à la
retraite aura pour effet de geler ou de
restreindre l'accès des jeunes un
premier emploi
merci chers collègues
bon donc on va jouer sur le 783 alors
monsieur le rapporteur explications de
vote le pardon l'avis de la commission
l'avis de la commission bien sûr il aidé
des favoris et monsieur ministre
défavorable monsieur la demande
d'explications de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent l'adopter veuille bien levé
la main merci que ceux qui sont contre
vais bien levé la main
il n'est pas adopté nous passons aux 784
il l'est présentée par monsieur le
président en répondant à votre appel et
aussi à l'appel de madame la présidente
je vais défendre deux amendements pour
accélérer le processus moi j'ai été très
sensible à votre argumentation
oui nous sommes là pour vous distraire
si j'ai bien compris c'est ça alors on
va essayer d'être plus jovial alors oui
alors cet article 9 s'inscrit dans la
logique gouvernementale de réduction des
dépenses publiques hervé morin
d'ailleurs l'annoncé lui-même le
ministre des armées devrait voir son
budget diminuer de plus de 5 milliards
d'euros
incontestablement cet article qui
contribuera pour une bonne part quand
vous le savez les sénatrices et
sénateurs du groupe crc spg ne sont pas
opposés à une réduction du budget de ce
ministère à la double condition qu'elles
correspondent à une volonté de
réorientation des budgets notamment vers
la coopération internationale
l'éducation et à la condition que cette
réduction n'est pour effet de peser
lourdement sur les personnels civils
comme militaires
or le report de deux ans de l'âge légal
de départ à la retraite sans décote ne
respecte pas ce principe
raison pour laquelle nous y sommes
opposés
nous continuons à défendre l'idée selon
laquelle au lieu et place de la rgpp à
rgpp à la défense nationale il serait
profitable que cesse cette course à
l'armement notamment nucléaires les
personnels militaires et civils de la
défense nationale est appelée à
supporter une partie considérable de
cette réforme
nous vous proposons d'adopter ces deux
amendements
merci cher collègue monsieur rapporteur
quel est l'avis de la commission
c'est toujours le même
le présent avis défavorables pour ces
suppressions darjeeling
merci monsieur le ministre la vie
gouvernement même avis monsieur même
avis pas de demandes d'explications de
vote que ceux qui souhaitent adopter cet
amendement veuille bien levé la main
merci que ceux qui sont contre veuille
bien levé la main il n'est pas ils ne
sont pas adopté de façon à l'amendement
il est présenté par monsieur de mai elle
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je suis
doublement réjouit je me réjouis
doublement de présenter cet amendement
d'abord parce qu'il va rétablir un droit
et effacer une injustice par rapport aux
travailleurs handicapés et deuxièmement
parce que cet amendement est passé au
travers des mailles du filet de
l'article 40
ça m'étonne beaucoup en vain il est
passé au travers dans sa rédaction
actuelle le code des pensions civiles et
militaires ou un droit de départ
anticipé à la retraite pour les
fonctionnaires atteints d'une incapacité
permanente d'au moins 80% dans les
conditions similaires à celles en
vigueur pour les salariés relevant du
régime général
hors la loi du 27 juin 2006 a introduit
une majoration de pension afin de
compenser les aléas de carrière survie
subies par les fonctionnaires handicapés
et de neutraliser l'effet de la décote
sur leurs pensions qu'elle était
liquidée par anticipation ou non or la
nouvelle rédaction du code des pensions
civiles militaires l'article 24 euros
modifié par cet article nord justement
supprime la majoration de pension
actuellement accordées aux
fonctionnaires handicapés
cette suppression va fortement diminuer
le montant de la pension accordée aux
fonctionnaires bien évident
fonctionnaires handicapés
bien évidemment et risque ainsi de
limiter les possibilités de départ
anticipé à la retraite pour ses agents
donc cet amendement vise par conséquent
à maintenir le dispositif actuellement
en vigueur
et quand je vous ai parlé de l'article
40 et bien figurez-vous que j'avais un
autre amendement j'étais premier
signataire d'un amendement concernant
les handicapés et il a été aspiré par
vers la porte de sortie par l'article 40
il s'agissait de mettre fin à une
situation inéquitable en supprimant
supprimant la notion de charge effective
et en se référant uniquement au niveau
des ressources effectivement perçu par
l'orphelin lorsqu'il s'agissait de faire
bénéficier d'une pension de reversions
aux orphelins majeur est infirme
alors si je montre mon amendement
si je n'avais pas su lire l'article 9
je suis prêt à le retirer car quant à
l'amendement qui a été annulée supprimés
par l'article 40
vous savez il est tellement important
que je pense que j'ai enfin je ne
verrais pas d'inconvénient à ce qu'il
soit repris par la commission ou par le
gouvernement vous savez je ne cherche
pas à avoir de droits d'auteur si ça
doit satisfaire les intéressés c'est
d'abord ça qui compte le plus je vous
remercie
merci jacques alingue un monsieur le
rapporteur l'avis de la commission
mais seul présent je crois que l'auteur
de l'amendement fait une erreur d' art
et d'interprétation car le projet de loi
ne supprime absolument pas
la major a de passer de pension pour les
handicapés donc c'est un amendement qui
est satisfait la commission ne pourrait
donner qu'un avis défavorable on propose
de le retirer sinon merci le raconteur
monsieur ministre l'avis du gouvernement
merci monsieur le président c'est
évidemment le même avis que le celui du
rapporteur
il ya deux alinéas dans cet article est
autant le premier alinéa du
cinquièmement du 1 de l'article l 24 du
code des pensions et moi
et fier autant le deuxième alinéa qui
traitent directement de cette question
lui n'est pas modifiée donc comme le dit
très justement monsieur le rapporteur
l'amendement pourrait être retiré dans
la mesure où il est déjà satisfait
j'ajoute pour terminer en un mot comme
vous l'avez constaté quel que soit le
point de vue que l'on est sur l'ensemble
du projet doit monsieur le président
vous aurez noté que nous avons souhaité
manifester
combien il était important de prendre et
de traiter en quelques sortes à part la
question les problèmes liés aux
personnes handicapées on l'a vu dans
différents autres aspects du texte donc
évidemment nous avons free garde à ne
pas tomber dans ce travers qui serait
injustifiable
ils subissent chaque collègue et ils
retirer je suis le président monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le ministre vous
avez vu que j'ai pris des précautions
j'ai dit peut-être j'avais mal lu donc
et j'ai dit que j'étais prêt à le
retirer
je retire mais je vous fais la
proposition concernant la morale là
retenu l'amendement 155 dont j'étais le
premier signataire et qui a été retiré
par la commission des finances
vous n'êtes pas obligé de le reprendre
tout de suite vous pourrez toujours le
reprendre un peu plus loin dans
l'article 19 et même si c'est un
amendement du gouvernement ou un
amendement de la commission je vous
répète je ne verrai pas ombrage s'il
rétablit une certaine justice si vous
avez perdu le 155 parce que il a disparu
du listing des amendements déposés
je suis prêt a voulu remettre je pense
que quand on fait de grandes
déclarations concernant les retraites
pour les handicapés et bien que vous
n'êtes que le ministre monsieur woerth a
fait la semaine dernière
eh bien je pense que on doit tout à fait
normalement reprendre
l'amendement 155
que j'avais signé avec mes collègues du
groupe socialiste donc je retire le 139
et je vous supplie de reprendre le 155
parce que je ne peux pas le faire moi
même merci chers collègues nous passons
donc aux 786 madame térabits si monsieur
le président 7 786 propose de supprimer
les alinéas 9 à 10 est donc de cet
article 9 comme la grande m risque fort
de se faire discrète sur le devenir de
son code des pensions et de l'évolution
de ces retraites
nous sommes donc amenés avec cet
amendement a confirmé notre opposition à
la mise en oeuvre des dispositions
concrètes de cet article 9
quelles problématiques pose en effet
l'allongement de la période d'engagement
des militaires elles reculent de leur
âge de départ en retraite
une problématique évidente de
déroulement de carrière surtout dans un
contexte où la loi de programmation et
les différentes lois de finances
discutent et dans le prolongement
prévoit expressément un reformatage de
nos armées sur des effectifs et des
unités en nombre moins important
on peut en effet séparés on ne peut en
effet séparé ce problèmes de goulots
d'étranglement de l'ensemble de la
question des retraites
il est acquis à la lecture des éléments
budgétaires disponibles que le compte
des pensions militaires présentes un
évident problème de couverture un
problème de couverture liée à la fois
aux conditions particulières d'exercice
du droit à pension la durée de service
requis est moins longue et au décalage
croissant entre nombre de militaires en
activité et nombre de pensionnés il
s'agit donc de faire en sorte que
progressivement le régime de pensions
soient de plus en plus pris en charge
par ses propres ayants droit l'autre
problème bien entendu et que le nombre
des emplois libéré dans une unité
militaire sera en bout de course moins
important et moins élevé qu'on aurait pu
l'attendre
ce qui empêchera un renouvellement
conséquent des effectifs et peut
conduire sous certaines conditions à une
mise en cause de l'avancement de
militaires d'actifs plus jeune est
est-ce nécessairement ce que l'on
recherche ici si tel est le cas il faut
le préciser de suite sinon il faut bien
entendu voté en faveur de cet amendement
qui risque fort de conduire
à rendre encore moins opérationnel
l'armée française pour des motifs assez
peu essentiel de troubles cuisine
budgétaire merci cher collègue monsieur
le rapporteur l'avis du gouvernement
messieurs le posant chers collègues vous
sur notre gueule cet amendement donc
nous propose de supprimer les alinéas de
9 à 17 vous pensez bien que le texte
perd toute sa nature et donc avis
défavorable de la commission
merci le sur un porteur pour la
commission monsieur le ministre l'avis
du gouvernement la commission est
défavorable pour les mêmes raisons draps
l'occasion d'ailleurs dans les articles
suivants de rentrer plus à fond dans la
question des militaires et je voudrais
madame la sénatrice des éléments de
réponse qui j'en suis convaincue vous
permettront de modifier le jugement
critique que vous avez émis et sans
doute de retirer quelques uns des
prochains amendements merci monsieur le
ministre pas de demandes d'explications
de vote que ceux qui souhaitent
l'adopter veuille bien levé la main
merci que ceux qui sont contre et bien
levé la main il n'est pas adopté nous
passons à l'amendement
1225 monsieur le rapporteur oui vous le
savez donc le sénat devaient à l'article
6 un amendement qui a exclu du
relèvement de l'âge d'annulation de la
décote
les parents d'enfants handicapés or cet
article 6 ne concerne que le régime
général et les régimes et régimes
alignés donc par cet amendement
la commission des affaires sociales tant
à faire une coordination qui est
nécessaire est là pour la fonction
publique
merci monsieur l'inventeur monsieur
ministre l'avis du gouvernement merci
monsieur le président bak gouvernement
est évidemment favorable à cette à cet
amendement de la commission j'ai eu
l'occasion il ya quelques instants de
répondre au président de mai elle que
c'était sur ces questions liées au
handicap une des priorités du texte du
gouvernement que de prendre en compte la
situation tant des travailleurs
handicapés c'est ce que nous avons fait
que des parents de travail et handicapés
que des aidants des travailleurs
handicapés et donc tout naturellement
nous avons le souci de faire en sorte de
la fonction publique puisse bénéficier
pour les personnes handicapées les mêmes
dispositifs c'est la raison pour
laquelle la vie y est favorable
monsieur le ministre pas de demandes
d'explications de vote si madame le
texte lors du débat sur l'article 6 nous
avions voté l'amendement de monsieur
roux l'amendement du gouvernement
relatif aux parents qui s'étaient
arrêtées de travailler ou qui avait
ralenti leur activité professionnelle
pour s'occuper d'enfants handicapés
donc naturellement nous allons voter
cette amende merci monsieur fisher pour
explication de vote
nous avions eu la même attitude est donc
logique avec nous mêmes et par cohérence
et bien nous voterons à d'autres
demandes que ceux qui souhaitent adopter
cet amendement veut bien levé la main il
est adopté à l'unanimité nous sommes
votons sur l'article 9
explications de vote pas d'explications
de vote que ceux qui souhaitent adopter
l'article 9 bien levé la main
merci que ceux qui sont contre veuille
bien levé la main il est adopté
nous arrivons l'article 9 bis et j'ai
une demande de parole de monsieur fichés
pardon monsieur fisher quel enchaînement
alors comme vous le savez la loi du 21
août 2003 relatif à la réforme des
retraites a mis en place un dispositif
permettant la prise en compte dans la
durée d'assurance des périodes d'études
n'ayant pas donné lieu à la filiation à
un régime d'assurance vieillesse
un dispositif dont le principal mérite
est de soulever sans doute pour la
première fois la question de la prise en
compte des périodes d'enseignement dans
les droits à retraite alors toutefois ce
dispositif est bien trop contraignant
puisque les périodes d'études concernés
doivent avoir donné lieu à l'obtention
d'un diplôme
l'admission dans les grandes écoles et
classes préparatoires à ces écoles étant
assimilé à l'obtention d'un diplôme
mais surtout il repose sur le principe
du rachat
c'est à dire qu'il ne bénéficie qu'à
celles et ceux qui disposent de moyens
financiers leur permettant de racheter
ces années
aussi si ce dispositif est louable il
repose en quelque sorte sur un mécanisme
de capitalisation puisque la sueur et
s'achète des droits propres et s'inspire
du modèle assurantielle commercial où
les assurés peuvent décider de racheter
leur franchise
donc pour notre part nous considérons
qu'il est possible avec un autre
financement est souhaitable de faire en
sorte que titre de la solidarité
chaque année de scolarité comme chaque
année de formation puisse ouvrir des
droits à la retraite
or comme vous le savez le relèvement des
deux bornes d'âge et l'augmentation de
la durée de cotisation ont pour effet de
rendre inutile certains des versements
qui ont déjà f été effectué alors afin
de ne pas pénaliser des salariés qui
devront déjà subir ce projet de loi et
qui ont fait le choix de ce rachat
nous nous opposerons pas
nous ne nous opposerons pas à l'adoption
de cet article merci chers collègues
nous avons deux amendements qui font
l'objet d'une discussion commune tout
d'abord l'amendement 141 même confiant
cet article 9 bis qui a été ajouté lors
de la discussion à l'assemblée nationale
prévoit donc la possibilité d'obtenir un
remboursement de trimestres rachetés et
en effet du fait du relèvement de l'âge
d'ouverture du droit à pension
certains de ces rachats de trimestres
vont devenir inutile des assurés qui ont
effectué des versements pour compléter
leur durée d'assurance devront différé
en effet leur départ en retraite du fait
de la réforme sur laquelle nous nous
travaillons entraînant ainsi une
augmentation de leur nombre de
trimestres cotisés et en prenant pour
hypothèse que les assurés concernés
resteront actifs jusqu'à l'âge légal de
départ en retraite
la caisse nationale d'assurance
vieillesse a évalué entre 171 et 277
millions le coût du remboursement pour
le régime général
selon que les assurés demande le
remboursement des seuls trimestre
devenus inutiles ou la totalité des
trimestres rachetés
les 9000 salariés concernés ont racheté
54 milles trimestre nous indique la cnav
dont une partie en vain le chèque moyen
à restituer à chacun de ses cotisants
serait de 22 mille euros les sommes qui
ont été déboursés au moment du rachat
ont constitué une privation pour les
ménages et il est donc juste qu'ils
puissent être en mesure d'en solliciter
le remboursement
c'est pourquoi nous vous proposons cet
amendement qui vise à informer les
assurés qui ont été prudents et qui
avait anticipé leurs trimestres leur
déficit de trimestres cotisés que leurs
achats devient sans cause et qu'ils
peuvent en solliciter le remboursement
et nous souhaitons
que c'est l'obligation d'information
soit inscrite dans le texte de la loi
afin que effectivement chacun soit
informé que les sommes versées doivent
bien revenir aux assurés merci chers
collègues
l'amendement 300 de madame demontès oui
monsieur le président mais sur ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur
cet amendement vise à compléter
l'amendement comme ma collègue claire
lise campion vient de défendre est
relatif à l'information nécessaire des
personnes concernées par les
dispositions de cet article 9 bis donc
je ne vais pas reprendre évidemment
l'argumentation qui a été développé sur
la nécessité de faire connaître aux
assurés concernés les modalités de
rachat de trimestres de cotisation pour
leurs années d'études
mais il me paraît opportun de préciser
comme nous l'avons déjà fait d'ailleurs
sur d'autres articles que ces personnes
doivent être informés qu'elle réside en
france ou à l'étranger
en effet les français s'établissent de
plus en plus fréquemment hors de nos
frontières et nombre d'entre eux sont
affiliés à un régime de retraite concèze
il doit donc bénéficier également de
l'information la plus complète possible
sur leurs droits et notamment sur la
nécessité de faire la demande dans les
trois ans suivant l'entrée en vigueur de
cette loi d'un remboursement de
cotisations je vous remercie
merci cher collègue monsieur le
rapporteur l'avis de la commission oui
monsieur le président donc le premier
amendement le 141 prévoit de manière et
pensons-nous tout à fait utile
l'information des assurés qui sont
concernés sur cette possibilité donc de
remboursement des trimestres qu'ils ont
racheté est sûr c'est un remboursement
qui deviennent utiles du fait de la
réforme
en plus ils ne sont pas très nombreux
cette information peut-être nous
semble-t-il délivré assez facilement
dans kavi favorable de la commission sur
le trottoir le revenu
oui aussi
vous savez c'est à dire avec il passe
avec mais qui peut être parti qui
rachète en étant à l'étranger on
pourrait se poser la question alors
l'avis du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président écoute et
nous sommes favorables à un amendement
en ce sens je me trompe dans les 141
voilà c'est l'information demander un
remboursement le rachat on est d'accord
j'ai pas de jeu pas évidemment de
problème sur le deuxième c'est pas la
même chose si je comprends bien c'est
plutôt la silla les rachats c'est à
l'étendre aux étrangers d'accord ok
sagesse j'aurai donc les djs d'accord
très bien explications de vote monsieur
fisher bon bien entendu nous voterons
ces deux amendements qui tendent à
compléter l'article 9 bis en précisant
que les salariés qui ont procédé au
rachat d'une partie de leurs années
d'études sont informés de la possibilité
qu'offre cet article de pouvoir
bénéficier d'un tel remboursement
je crois que c'est l'évidence c'est la
sagesse qui s'est exprimé
l'article 3 d'ailleurs de ce projet de
loi prévoit clairement que les assurés
sont informés et il faut refaire la
liaison de leur situation quant au
niveau de l'an droits à retraite
beaucoup d'entre vous on séance publique
comme en commission des affaires
sociales salué l'avancée que constitue
cet article même si aussi pour notre
part alors bon il ya toujours cette
arrière-pensée d'inciter lé travail
or à renforcer la part de capitalisation
dans leur retraite
aussi nous semble important que les
salariés puissent disposer d'une
information claire y compris sur la
possibilité de bénéficier d'un tel
rachat
en effet sans publicité en direction des
personnes directement concernées il y à
fort à craindre que ce dispositif ne
soit que partiellement utilisé ce qui je
l'espère n'est pas votre volonté mais là
on salue la position qui vient d'être
prise et bien sûr nous voterons ces deux
amendements
merci cher collègue madame demontès vos
explications de vote oui juste très très
rapidement juste un point de de
précisions parce que l'amendement numéro
300 2 intègre aussi les éléments du 141
nous allons retirer le 141 et nous
allons maintenir le 302 oui on est
d'accord très bien donc le 141e retirer
je vous propose de voter sur le 302 qui
souhaitent adopter mercy il est adopté
nous votons sur l'article 9 bis pas de
demandes d'explications de vote que ceux
qui souhaitent adopter veut bien levé la
main merci il est adopté
nous en arrivons chapitre 2 sur la
limite d'âge et mise à la retraite
d'office sur cet article 10 chez une
demande de parole de monsieur fisher
sur le dise l'article 10 10
madame de madame david monsieur fisher
nom très bien excusez moi monsieur le
président je réponds compris 10 j'ai
compris bis alors je me demandais de
calvi s'il s'agissait monsieur le
président monsieur me disent mes chers
collègues rallongée de deux ans l'âge
permettant de bénéficier de la retraite
retarder de deux ans en portant à 60 à
67 ans l'âge auquel pourrait prétendre
les salariés pour bénéficier d'une
retraite sans décote ne vous suffit
apparemment pas puisque vous réaffirmer
votre volonté de voir certains
fonctionnaires à travailler le plus
longtemps possible
raison pour laquelle depuis le projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2009 vous avez modifié les
règles en matière de mise à la retraite
d'office
ainsi à fonctionnaires pourraient
décider s'ils le souhaitent de
travailler jusqu'à l'année de ses 70 ans
en ce sens l'article dit ce n'est pas
une innovation il est la continuité
logique de votre politique
d'ailleurs il n'y aurait rien de
scandaleux selon votre majorité à ce que
des salariés qui le souhaitent qu'ils
seraient volontaires puissent travailler
jusqu'à 70 ans
sauf qu'en réalité la liberté des
salariés est contrebalancé par les
réalités que vivent nos concitoyens
prévoir une telle mesure que ce soit
dans la fonction publique comme dans le
secteur privé ne suffit pas encore
faut-il s'assurer que le niveau des
pensions soit suffisant pour pouvoir
liquider sa retraite plus tôt si on le
souhaite mais aussi que les travailleurs
qui ont subi des conditions de travail
particulièrement difficiles ou qui ont
commencé à travailler très jeunes
puissent bénéficier d'une retraite
anticipée
toutefois connaissant l'attachement de
nos concitoyennes et concitoyens à la
retraite à 60 ans et il le sait il ne
cesse de le montrer
manifestation après manifestation la
prochaine ce sera pour demain
ensuite pour mardi cet article a plus
une portée symbolique qu'effective il
s'agit pour vous l'air de rien
d'inscrire dans la loi et surtout dans
les têtes
l'idée selon laquelle il serait possible
pour qu'ils le voudraient de travailler
jusqu'à 70 ans
il ne vous suffit plus alors qu'à opérer
un léger basculement et rentrent
progressivement obligatoire ce qui est
aujourd'hui facultatif cet article
constitue un
beau coup de canif supplémentaire à
notre pacte social lequel est déjà bien
en taille et depuis l'élection de
nicolas sarkozy à la présidence de la
république
mais au-delà de ces au delà cet article
nous interroge sur la société que nous
sommes en train de construire
et force est de constater que l'idée que
nous nous faisons d'une société de
progrès et de solidarité est à l'opposé
et chers collègues de celles que vous
voulez merci chers collègues nous
passons donc à l'amendement 44
il est présenté par monsieur vers un
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues par cet
amendement de suppression
nous souhaitons affirmer notre
opposition à cet article qui recule de 2
années l'âge auquel les salariés peuvent
être mis à la retraite d'office avec cet
article
la limite d'âge passerait à 69 ans
révolus on pourrait donc travailler
jusqu'à l'année de ses 70 ans
c'est donc le franchissement d'un seuil
c'est le quatrième âge au travail et
ceci constitue une grave régression
sociale
nous contestons la nécessité de recourir
à un recul de l'âge de départ en
retraite sous couvert de l'argument
d'une prétendue urgence démographique
assis sur des projections hasardeuse
pour financer notre système de retraite
par répartition
cette position est d'ailleurs confortée
par le fait que le présent projet
n'assure en aucun cas un financement
équilibré à l'horizon 2018
or un financement pérenne est tout à
fait envisageable sans mettre en
difficulté l'économie de notre pays
comme le démontre notre proposition de
loi numéro 2679 cette proposition de loi
montre que d'autres solutions peuvent
sont possibles car avec votre réforme
il s'agit comme le disait le numéro deux
du medef de supprimer tous les acquis de
la libération de démanteler
progressivement le programme du cnr
fondé sur la solidarité nationale et
inter
générationnel nous pensons pour notre
propre pour notre part que ce programme
est toujours d'actualité et que la
retraite paraît pas être par répartition
reste une idée d'avenir une idée moderne
pour cette raison et parce que nous
pensons que les salariés ont le droit
après une vie de labeur de profiter
d'une retraite méritée
nous demandons la suppression de cet
article ces chers collègues sur un
porteur l'avis de la commission
l'avis de la commission est défavorable
car actuellement dans sa rédaction
actuelle le salarié pourrait de droit
rester à son poste jusqu'à son 72e
anniversaire
si j'ai bien écouté vos propos c'est
parce que vous voulez donc on ne va pas
vous suivent assume en supprimant cet
article donc avis défavorable de la
commission monsieur l'inventeur monsieur
ministre l'avis du gouvernement oui
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les dessinateurs se serait
assez paradoxal en supprimant cet
article vous repousse riez à 72 ans en
réalité l'âge où un un employeur ne
pourrait pas pourrait mettre à la
retraite d'office un salarié dont je dis
pas que c'est ce que vous voulez je ne
dis pas que c'est ce que vous voulez
mais ça aboutirait à cela donc nous
maintenons cette âge 70 ans sillage de
la liberté je veux dire de si le salarié
veut continuer à travailler au fond c -
lille c'est pas de liberté pour
l'employeur si l'employeur ne peut pas
le mettre à la retraite d'office mais
visant le salarié peut prendre sa
retraite au moment où il le souhaite
dans les conditions de la retraite et en
même temps d'ailleurs si cohérent avec
la politique que nous menons
on prend d'ailleurs que puissent y être
opposés mais c'est de se dire si on a
envie de travailler on peut cumuler
l'emploi et la retraite on peut voir il
ya plusieurs plusieurs possibilités pour
continuer à travailler pour ceux qui
souhaitent continuer à travailler soit
je suis opposé évidemment votre
rendement merci monsieur le ministre
explications de vote pas d'explications
de vote que ceux qui souhaitent adopter
vais bien levé la main
que ceux qui sont contre eux veulent
bien levé la main il n'est pas adopté
nous passons à deux amendements qui font
l'objet d'une discussion commune
l'amendement 911 il est présenté par
monsieur fisher alors avec d'autres
amendements nous proposons de supprimer
l'article 90 de la loi de finances nous
proposions de supprimer l'article 90 de
la loi de finances de la sécurité
sociale heures bon c'était ont fait un
article qui traitait de la mise en
retraite d'office après 65 ans qui est
symbolique de la situation faite d'un
côté aux jeunes qui ne trouvent pas
d'emploi et de l'autre aux seniors qui
sont contraints de travailler plus
longtemps quand ils trouvent un emploi
bien sûr alors on c'est un débat que
vient de rappeler le ministre d'ailleurs
les entreprises préfèrent je le rappelle
se séparer ou refuser d'embaucher des
salariés de plus de 50 ans et on
constate que les taux d'emploi baisse
fortement et régulièrement à partir de
55 ans travailler après 65 ans n'est pas
se fera exception un choix de vie comme
on a pu l'entendre dire parfois et bien
sûr sondés philosophie fondamentalement
différente
les personnes qui demandent à travailler
après 65 ans le font parce qu'elles ont
comme seule perspective la plupart du
temps une retraite trop faible ou cela
s'adresse à des catégories de cadres
supérieurs de direction bon on sait
qu'il y a une
certains hauts fonctionnaires bien alors
ces salariés ne sont pas ne sont
pourtant pas les responsables de leur
situation
c'est bien souvent la solidarité
nationale qui a failli puisqu'elle ne
leur permet pas de faire face aux
dépenses
d'ailleurs de la vie courante aux
dépenses de soins et on s'aperçoit que
de plus en plus de monde prolonge sa
durée de travail
et la vraie question de science du
financement des retraites ce n'est pas
l'allongement de la durée du travail
mais bien je crois l'insuffisance bon à
la fois de cotisation qui entrent dans
les caisses de la sécurité sociale du
fait des politiques d'exonération la
garantie de l'avenir des retraites passe
nécessairement par une remise en cause
de ces exonérations une remise à plat
des ex des cotisations patronales aussi
dont bénéficient bien tous les membres
du medef pratiquement elle passe par
l'accès de tous à l'emploi donc il le
faut en finir avec une valeur ajoutée
qui est très inégalement réparties
puisque on s'aperçoit que la progression
aux aides des actionnaires est bien est
de plus en plus grand donc à travers cet
amendement et bien nous pensons et nous
réaffirmons que le travail doit être
structurellement bien rémunérés et que
nous devons dans ces conditions
bon j'ai essayé de tenter de justifier
cet amendement voilà monsieur le
président si sa collègue amendement 980
il est présenté par madame david oui
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je sais que ni vous ni monsieur
le rapporteur n'aime les rapports mais
il nous semblait important au vu de ce
que vous nous proposez avec cet article
et bien que le gouvernement justement
nous remettre au parlement un rapport
dans un délai d'un an à compter de la
promulgation de la loi afin de savoir
précisément qui parmi ses salariés qui
souhaitent travailler jusqu'à 60 l'année
de leurs 70 ans puisque c'est de ça dont
il est question
savoir qui parmi ses salariés se
retrouverait dans l'obligation de
travailler ou véritablement serait
volontaire pour travailler jusqu'à cet
âge là c'est ce que disait mon collègue
fischer à l'instant est-ce que parmi ces
salariés se retrouverait des personnes
en situation difficile où la retraite
qui les pousserait parce que leurs
pensions seraient trop faibles à aller
au delà de l'âge légal
et dans ces cas là évidemment nous ne
pouvons pas accepter de faire travailler
des salariés jusqu'à 70 ans
parce que leurs niveaux de pensions de
pension est trop faible
soit ce seront des salariés qui
volontairement voudront travailler
jusqu'à 70 ans par ce qu'ils auront des
postes et des métiers des plus
intéressants valorisant et qui leur
donne une grande satisfaction
dans ces cas là je trouve ça tout à fait
injuste également car très souvent dans
ces cas là les personnes qui restent
jusqu'à 70 ans est bien empêche d'autres
jeunes personnes de pouvoir accéder à
ces postes et je trouve qu'il ya là une
certaine injustice qui n'est pas très
très bonne vis-à-vis de nos jeunes
bien évidemment pas les jeunes à la
recherche d'un premier emploi parce que
là pour le coup il ne s'agirait pas de
poste en début de carrière mais en fin
de carrière je trouve injuste de priver
certains salariés qui pourraient
bénéficier de ces promotions
donc voilà en plus dans ce rapport nous
souhaiterions également avoir la part
entre les femmes et les hommes notamment
et ça rejoint un petit peu la première
la première raison de ce rapport c'est à
dire que nous craignons que trop de
femmes arrivées à l'âge de la retraite
n'est pas une pension suffisante pour
qu'elle soit obligée de continuer à
travailler jusqu'à jusqu'à l'année de
leurs 70 ans
et là pour le coup ce serait
complètement inacceptable
déjà le report à 67 ans pour nous est
inacceptable alors si en plus vous les
autoriser à l'est jusqu'à 70 c'est
complètement inacceptable voilà le sens
de ce rapport je sais bien que c'est un
rapport de plus comme je l' ai déjà
entendu ni le rapporteur ni le
gouvernement ne sont très
comment dire enthousiaste à l'idée d'un
rapport supplémentaire mais il me semble
quand même que danser selon sein du fait
de du sujet de ce rapport excusez moi du
sujet de ce rapport il me semble
important que nous puissions quand même
l'obtenir merci cher collègue monsieur
rapportant l'avis de la commission
monsieur le président par l'amendement
de 911 ou ne vous nous demandez donc de
revenir sur les dispositions du plfss
2009 qui ont relevé d'emblée
l'âge de la mise à la retraite d'office
ou comprendrait que la commission a émis
un avis défavorable pour le second c'est
vrai que c'est un rapport de plus bon il
est formulé en termes assez vague mais
toutes ces données statistiques on peut
les recueillir déjà auprès des
différents régimes donc là aussi avis
défavorable mais rssi monsieur
rapporteur même identique pour le
gouvernement monsieur ministe merci donc
sur le 911 explications de vote
il n'y en a pas que ceux qui souhaitent
l'adopter veuille bien levé la main
merci que ceux qui sont contre veut bien
levé la main il n'est pas adoptée sur
les 980 même vote même vote
nous votons sur l'article 10 à deux
demandes d'explications de vote que ceux
qui souhaitent l'adopter veut bien levé
la main merci que ceux qui sont contre
veuille bien levé la main il est adopté
non je déconne
nous passons à l'article 11 et j'ai donc
une demande de parole de monsieur 2 mai
elle merci monsieur le président
messieurs
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues cet article 11 et finalement
le frère jumeau de l'article 10 10
puisque il concerne le relèvement de
l'âge où on peut prendre la retraite à
taux plein qui est de 65 ans et qui
passerait à 67 ans au passage
j'ouvre une parenthèse c'est que il
passerait de 65 à 67 ans en cinq ans si
bien que jusqu'à maintenant on est y
avait habitué au mieux à la notion de
trimestre et là tout d'un coup on passe
à une notion nouvelle de quadrimestre je
vous laisse imaginer les petites
difficultés qui va y avoir pour les
systèmes informatiques
parce que tout est sur les trimestres là
pour ça sera passé par tous les quatre 4
mois mais pense à ceux ci est
anecdotique
alors finalement 7 cette disposition ne
concerne que 17 % des assurés sociaux
que 17%
pourquoi parce que une bonne partie
seront déjà parti soit parce qu'ils sont
fatigués et qu'il souhaite partir à 60
ans ou à 62 ans sur la période et il ne
restera que 10 7% qui atteindront cet
âge qui atteignent aujourd'hui cet âge
de 55 65 ans mais qui sont ils
c'est avant tout et surtout des femmes
c'est sûr que les femmes pour 22%
ce sont des femmes qui doivent attendre
pour avoir une retraite à taux plein
compte tenu d'une carrière en pointillé
ce sont les femmes qui seront donc les
plus pénalisées on l'a dit
je m'excuse on l'a déjà dit peut-être
c'est un mieux de le dire mais moi je le
répète c'est les femmes qui vont être
pénalisés puisque elle elle pouvait
prétendre avoir le taux plein à 65 ans
et bien là il faudrait que l'art est un
peu plus jusqu'à 67 ans j'ai dit
l'essentiel mais comme aujourd'hui pour
moi c'est la journée session de
rattrapage pour les amendements qui ont
été aspirés par l'article 40 vers la
porte de sortie
je voudrais monsieur le ministre vous
alerter et je répète cet amendement s'il
a été retiré mais je ne verrai pas
ombrage à ce que vous leur preniez parce
que moi je peux le faire ou que la
commission le reprenne de quoi s'agit-il
eh bien figurez vous que dans la
fonction publique et territoriale et
hospitalière je crois qu'il faut que
lucas d'état il y a ceux qu'on appelle
les congés spéciaux
or un congé spécial dure cinq ans et la
plupart de ceux qui ont pris un congé
spécial l'ombrie à 60 ans ils ont pris à
60 ans et mais au bout des cinq ans
le couperet va tomber et ils n'auront
plus le congé spécial mais le problème
c'est qu'ils auront 60 ans et ils
n'auront pas l'âge de prendre la
retraite puisque il faudra attendre 67
ans
autrement dit là il ya une pénalisation
qui est tout de même gênant j'ai proposé
à l'article 9 après l'article 9 comme
corrige et comme prolonge jusqu'à l'âge
auquel ils pouvaient prétendre la
commission des finances est passée par
là et il paraît que ça va grandement
pénalisé les finances publiques
écoutez il s'agit d'une poignée de
personnes
je pense qu'on pourrait faire l'effort
et surtout quand on va se trouver devant
une situation ils ne pourront pas
prendre la retraite et ce sont sans
salaire et sans passion
alors que tu y viendrons vous voir pour
voir
comment en règle cette question je vous
remercie merci cher collègue monsieur
muller à la parole monsieur le président
messieurs les ministres c'est le
rapporteur madame la présidente chers
collègues le financement des retraites
repose depuis toujours quasi
exclusivement sur la masse salariale à
la csg près ce dispositif avec toute sa
cohérence aux sorties de la deuxième
guerre mondiale
mais en un demi siècle la donne a
radicalement changé
sur le plan macroéconomique et à deux
niveaux personne ne peut contester
d'abord une hausse historique de la
productivité du travail liée non
seulement aux nouvelles organisations du
travail mais aussi aux progrès
fantastiques des technologies mises en
oeuvre
deuxième grand changement c'est
l'explosion des revenus du capital qui
ne constituait qu'une fraction minime du
pib à la fin des trente glorieuses la
conversion au néolibéralisme des élites
dirigeantes dans les années 80 induit un
développement sans précédent des marchés
financiers de cette économie casino qui
plombent l'activité économique en
prélevant sur la valeur ajoutée ce qui
freine l'investissement l'activité
économique et l'emploi
un développement sans précédent des
marchés financiers qui exigent des
dividendes exorbitants reversée aux
ménages essentiellement les plus riches
oui nos sociétés ont évolué en
profondeur pas seulement sur le plan
démographique avec le déséquilibre
croissant actifs inactifs mais aussi sur
le plan macroéconomique ignorait cette
donne se cantonner à une approche
exclusivement démographique pour tenter
de rééquilibrer le système de retraite
en s'appuyant sur la masse salariale
n'est pas seulement profondément injuste
pour les salariés notamment les plus
modestes les plus fragiles exposés aux
travaux les plus durs et les femmes
cette posture relève au choix
de la règlement du conservatisme d'une
certaine mauvaise foi ou de ce que je
serais bien tenté d'appeler par son nom
une alliance de classe cette crispation
sur un financement reposant
exclusivement sur la masse salariale
prend évidemment un relief particulier
dans la fonction publique puisque le
gouvernement se prépare en 2011 à
liquider 34 mille postes de
fonctionnaires cherchez l'erreur
le dogme du non remplacement d'un
fonctionnaire sur deux qui résulte de la
tristement célèbre rgpp réforme générale
des politiques publiques va certes
permettre à l'état d'économiser 400
millions d'euros mais c'est pas de se
traduire aussi par la baisse
correspondante de la masse salariale et
donc des bases de cotisation
messieurs le ministre vous accentuez
ainsi le déficit des retraites des
régimes de retraite correspondant est la
réponse que vous apportez est
rigoureusement inacceptable travailler
plus longtemps et augmenter les
cotisations en période de gel
structurelle des salaires nominaux dans
la fonction publique c'est-à-dire
accentué la baisse du pouvoir d'achat
alors pour terminer je souhaite revenir
sur les effets de cette détestable rgpp
qu'il faut enfin appelé par son nom
la réduction généralisée des personnels
publics messieurs les ministres sortez
de votre tour d'ivoire aller sur le
terrain
dialoguer enfin vraiment avec les
infirmières et autres personnels de
santé qui n'en peuvent plus incapable de
répondre à des besoins croissants avec
un personnel toujours plus réduit avec
les enseignants et l'ensemble de la
communauté éducative
confronté à des problèmes sociétaux
croissant avec des moyens en diminution
les travailleurs sociaux qui font face à
la multiplication des situations
dramatiques
crise oblige mais sans être soutenu avec
les gardiens de prison chargé de gérer
des détenus toujours plus nombreux
politiques répressives oblige avec des
effectifs des croissants ce qui finit
par poser des problèmes de sécurité
notamment dans les centrales avec les
policiers chargés du maintien de l'ordre
dans une société qui se délite
avec l'ensemble des acteurs du service
public
dans la charge de travail administratif
explose complexification de nos
procédures oblige tous je dis bien tous
sans exception sont atterrés par ce qui
est en train de se passer
la destruction méthodique d'un piliers
de notre pacte républicain
nos services publics construit
progressivement depuis la deuxième
guerre mondiale et qui sont tout
simplement le marqueur d'une société
développée
permettez moi messieurs les ministres de
douter de votre attachement au service
public je cite que vous vous efforcez
d'influx d'affiché alors réforme des
retraites plus rgpp franchement on ne
pouvait pas faire pire et les verts
voteront pour la suppression de cet
article 11
si chers collègues la parole était un
homme qui a ri merci monsieur le
président monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
cet article 11 prévoit le relèvement
progressif des deux années de la limite
d'âge dans la fonction publique
c'est en fait la voiture balai pour
n'oublier aucun fonctionnaire vous avez
fait passer avec l'article 5
l'âge légal de la retraite de 60 à 62
ans et avec l'article 6 de 65 à 67 ans
le relèvement de la limite d'âge
proposées par cet article est la
conséquence du recul de l'âge de la
retraite qui va être quoi que vous
puissiez on dire brutale nos concitoyens
l'ont bien compris qui manifestent avec
force leur opposition à cette réforme et
à votre méthode d'abord pour le régime
général et avec le présent article pour
les fonctionnaires sédentaires
tout cela est cohérent avec votre
idéologie je ne vais donc pas prendre la
parole pour dénoncer le simple article
11 mai pour refuser l'ensemble des
modifications que vous suggérez
cet article met en évidence votre
volonté de mettre au pas également les
fonctionnaires ma défense sera dès lors
celle de tous les travailleurs et non
d'une catégorie particulière
le découpage du texte facilite le
brouillage des questions alors que le
recul aiglons
al général et de ce fait condamnable
mais je rappellerai également comme cela
a été dit par mes collègues que dans la
fonction publique il n'y a pas que les
fonctionnaires de catégorie a
il y à tous ceux des autres catégories
qui ont souvent des petits salaires et
qui ont des emplois à forte pénibilité
et féministe vous ne pouvez pas
l'ignorer pour soutenir ce double recul
de 2 ans vous arrivez vous arguez sans
cesse de la situation démographique
c'est un argument souvent employé les
chiffres sont connus je n'y reviens pas
je suis cependant très surprise car la
réforme de 2003 que l'on nous présentait
alors comme la panacée
la grande réforme censée résoudre
l'ensemble des problèmes de manière
durable
c'est visiblement révélé comme elle
suffisante la réforme de 2003 n'a rien
réglé
pourtant les données démographiques et
elle est même à l'époque
l'embêtant avec la démographie c'est
qu'il s'agit d'une science sur le long
terme et de surcroît assez exacte il est
difficile de la faire mentir ceux qui
prévalaient en 2003 est toujours valable
de nos jours est rien finalement n'a
changé sur le fond
la vérité c'est que votre politique que
c'est que c'est votre politique qui
cause cette détérioration des comptes et
alourdit les déficits
le problème démographique que vous
pointez si souvent n'est qu'un alibi un
paravent pour masquer votre véritable
échec la politique économique que vous
menez ne donne aucun résultat
si ce n'est le creusement des déficits
et une santé économique déplorable de
notre pays alors par les retraites c'est
aussi parler emploi et c'est là en
l'occurrence par les emplois publics
nous pouvons aussi parlé de nos services
publiques rgpp qui cassent et cela a été
dit par mon collègue muller qui cassent
nos services publics
vous ne mesurez pas les conséquences du
remplacement d'un fonctionnaire sur deux
et qui pèse sur l'ensemble nos
fonctionnaires magistrats policiers
médecins infirmiers instituteurs etc qui
manquent sur tout le territoire plutôt
que de vous interroger sur le bien fondé
de vos orientations
vous préférez en remettre une couche en
fragilisant encore par le présent texte
les fonctionnaires c'est bel et bien une
réforme injuste et inefficace
je rappelle que les fonctionnaires ne
sont pas des privilégiés comme vous
tenté souvent de le faire croire pour
reposer les fonctionnaires à ceux du
privé
mais comme dans tous les secteurs il y à
des situations différencier dont vous ne
prenait absolument pas compte et qu'il y
à beaucoup d'emplois difficile dans la
fonction publique de tous petits
salaires mais aussi beaucoup de
précarité notamment chez les
contractuels parce que chacun d'entre
nous doit beaucoup à tous les agents du
service public parce qu'ils ont assuré
notre formation parce qu'ils assurent
notre sécurité
parce qu'ils se préoccupent de notre
santé parce que les services publics ils
nous rendent sont le patrimoine de ceux
qui n'en n'ont pas nous souhaitons la
suppression de cet article qui est à
l'image du texte un assemblage
idéologique qui servent qui se pare d'un
courage politique qui n'a pas pour mieux
masquer vos échecs
nous demandons donc la suppression de
cet article merci chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur fisher oui
l'application de ce texte à la fonction
publique
oui en même temps ça vaudra pour la
défense de l'abondement 18 d'accord
alors l'application de ce texte à la
fonction publique est une illustration
cruel de l'absurdité de cette réforme
bariza khiari vient de le rappeler
selon le gouvernement le système
français de retraite est confrontée à
des déficits qui résultent ray alors du
vieillissement démographique des des
salariés et cette explication est biaisé
car elle permet de passer sous silence
l'échec de la droite en matière de
création d'emplois et de comblement des
déficits publics et j'ai en effet le
chômage de masse ou encore les
exonérations de charges sociales sont
autant de pertes qui grèvent le budget
des retraites et le gouvernement qui a
fait le bilan des suppressions d'emplois
a dit que près de 100000 avait été déjà
supprimé sur quelques années là et qu'il
se fixait l'objectif d'en supprimer
encore cent mille d'ici 2013 2014
donc on voit bien que l'objectif est
bien c'est par ces suppressions
d'emplois concourir au démantèlement des
fonctions publiques
or face à cela qu fait le gouvernement
et ceux qui l'ont précédé
certes depuis 2002 mais aujourd'hui le
gouvernement se lance à corps perdu dans
une politique forcené de suppressions
massives de postes de fonctionnaires
chaque année ce sont plus de trente
mille postes de fonctionnaires 34000
l'année prochaine qui seront supprimés
avec des effets dévastateurs sur les
services publics
il y à qu'a mentionné le gouffre dans
lequel se trouve l'éducation nationale
qui a vu ses posts diminué de façon
exponentielle pour comprendre
en l'espace de quelques années ce sont
des centaines de milliers d'emplois qui
ont été détruits
renvoyant autant de personnes sera
marché de l'emploi complètement saturé
et tout fait au final ce
sont autant de personnes qui sont venues
rejoindre les rangs des chômeurs des
intérimaires des cdd des temps partiels
et autres sous-emploi sous payés c'est à
dire toute la cohorte donc des emplois
atypiques
c'est également autant de rentrées de
cotisations en moins de dépenses en
assurance chômage et autres prestations
sociales en plus hors victime d'une
surdité qui frise à l'autisme
le gouvernement continue sa politique
antisociale et contre productive
c'est ce que je disais c'est du tas de
chair à la puissance 10 en voulant
réhaussé l'âge légal de la retraite pour
les fonctionnaires et ainsi embouteillée
encore plus l'accès à la fonction
publique
outre les effets dévastateurs sur
l'emploi cela aura des conséquences
désastreuses sur les conditions de
travail des fonctionnaires en poste et
les témoignages affluent pour nous
parler de l'asphyxient notamment des
services publics puisque maintenant les
fonctionnaires pour pouvoir travailler
et bien sont obligés d'interdire ou de
fermer les services à l'accès au public
un certain nombre de demi journée à
titre d'exemple alors que l'éducation
nationale souffre d'un déficit chronique
de postes de professeurs et qu'elle doit
faire face en son sein aux répercussions
des politiques antisociales sur la
jeunesse pouvez vous imaginer que l'on
demande un professeur de 62 ans de
continuer à enseigner dans de telles
conditions
alors dans l'armée on rappelle les
retraités quand il ya des écoutes
bourrin excusez moi l'expression
eh bien on va en arriver là c'est à dire
sollicités de plus en plus les retraités
est bloqué en fait la création de poste
cette réforme ne résout aucun problème
elle me fait que les déplacés en
appliquant la fonction publique le
réhaussement de l'âge de la retraite le
gouvernement troc des retraités contre
des chômeurs et détériore encore plus
les conditions de travail des
fonctionnaires est ce que l'on voit
émerger
mais d'une manière très importante eh
bien c'est la précarité c'est à dire que
de plus en plus par le biais de la
contractualisation et bien on se trouve
confronté de plus en plus à l'explosion
de la précarité dans les fonctions
publiques d'où l'incertitude sur
l'avenir d'où le mécontentement qui se
manifestent dans les rues
merci jacques collègues la parole est à
madame david non c'est bon alors la
parole était monsieur assouline
oui la touche un débat sur la fonction
publique et les conséquences de cette
réforme pour les fonctionnaires et à ce
moment là je voudrais qu'on ouvre les
yeux sur un élément particulier des
conséquences si nous débattons c'est
parce que il y à une réforme qui est
venu s'imposer comme incontournable et
très souvent notre débat à quelque chose
d'extraordinaire c'est qu'il a pu
éclairer métier par métier ce que ça
voulait dire concrètement et d'ailleurs
c'est le reflet du quelque chose
peut-être que le gouvernement n'a pas
compris c'est que la retraite ça
concerne tout le monde et
qu'indépendamment du matraquage et de la
propagande
chaque français dans sa situation
particulière aller à un moment de ce
débat regardez concrètement ce que ça
voulait dire pour lui demain et chaque
français se rencontrent
quelle que soit sa situation de
l'aggravation des choses est très
souvent et monsieur bourdin vous l'a dit
hier les jeunes même indépendamment de
leurs propres projections personnelles
sur ce qui se passera à leur retrait ce
qu'ils font peu c'est vrai regarde leurs
parents la situation de leurs parents
ils n'ont pas envie de voir leur père ou
leur mère qu'ils ont souvent vu usées
par le travail travailler jusqu'à 67 ans
pour les fonctionnaires
nous avons une situation paradoxale où
en même temps et ça a été souligné qu'
il ya une réduction de moyens
il ya une pression presque de rendement
qui s'exerce sur les fonctionnaires et
qui a été constaté dans plusieurs
métiers que ce soit la police que ce
soit les enseignants et j'en passe
créer une situation particulière dans le
travail de stress de fatigue de
difficultés à rendre un service public
correcte malgré toute leur volonté avec
le mécontentement que ça produit pour
les usagers y compris le non
remplacement d'un fonctionnaire sur deux
je demande au ministre de bien regarder
la situation est d'ailleurs j'aurais
aimé qu'ils aient des projections qui
nous soit faite
on ne remplace pas un fonctionnaire sur
deux ça veut dire que les jeunes
rentrent moins dans la fonction publique
de fait puisque c'est les jeunes qui
remplace d'accord plus l'allongement de
l'âge de départ à la retraite
ça va mécaniquement en quelques temps et
de façon assez rapide faire vieillir le
corps le corps des fonctionnaires dans
tous ses métiers
il y aura un vieillissement plus fort et
plus accentuée que le vieillissement
lui-même de la population alors des
profs dans les situations que vous
connaissez monsieur le ministre
probablement dans des quartiers vous
assez difficile où déjà nous avons un
certain nombre de difficultés à faire
que les professeurs puissent aller au
travail avec enthousiasme jus les moyens
qu'on leur donne
ces endroits où un prof ou une prof à 67
ans et je veux ce jeudi une prof je veux
souligner le faire c'est encore les
femmes qui vont le plus traqué puisque
vous savez que par exemple pour les
professeurs ce sont les femmes qui sont
majoritaires dans ce métier et avec les
interruptions de carrière qu'elle que
tout le monde a souligné ici vous savez
très bien que
ces agents de la fonction publique
je vais aussi parler des policiers parce
que ça peut éclairer si si je suis ici
j'ai regardé de façon précise
globalement globalement il se passe que
par rapport à avant aujourd'hui à terme
on va dire les policiers pourront
travailler jusqu'à 64 ans vous imaginez
jusqu'à 64 ans pour le maintien de
l'ordre
c'est quand même une difficulté vous ne
voyez pas comment dans un corps qui doit
être assez dynamique qui est en proie à
des difficultés accrues à exercer le
métier parce que la société est beaucoup
plus difficile beaucoup plus
fractionnées que le service public est
quelque chose de plus compliqué à rendre
de façon égale sur tous les territoires
et quelles que soient les conditions
sociales faire vieillir ce corps et
obliger les fonctionnaires à travailler
plus longtemps alors que on réduit les
moyens et qu'on ne remplace pas un
fonctionnaire sur deux le cocktail est
explosif et les fonctionnaires ont
raison
quelle que soit leur situation de
rejeter cette réforme j'étais étonné de
voir dans les manifestations ont fait
étonné je constatais que dans les
manifestations les fonctionnaires que
l'on a décrit comme avantage et nantis
et cetera étaient massivement dans ces
manifestations et déterminés ils ont
raison et ils vont poursuivre la chose
merci cher collègue madame briques à la
parole oui puisqu'il s'agit
des fonctionnaires moi je voudrais
monsieur le ministre vous êtes compétent
sur ce sujet je voudrais à partir d'un
cas d'espèce qui m'a été soumis dans mon
département de cinéma mais qui est
révélateur de ce qui peut se passer
notamment dans l'éducation nationale et
qui n'est pas un cas unique parce que
nous faisons la loi donc nous défendons
évidemment l'intérêt général et ça
risque de se passer pour beaucoup
d'enseignants te souvent qu'ils sont
très inquiètes par rapport
aux textes de loi et qui fort
légitimement des longs dès lors qu'elles
ont leurs années de service et qu'elles
ont élevé trois enfants ont la
possibilité de partir et donc veulent le
faire avant que la loi soit
définitivement votée et promulguée
parce qu'elles sont très inquiètes par
le sort qui va leur être fait par cette
loi et il se trouve que à partir du
moment où on a les conditions pour
partir
on sait que l'application devrait être
en cours d'année c'est à dire que si
quelqu'un fait valoir ses droits au mois
d'avril
eh bien ce sera cela qui comptera et
elle a fait je suppose que d'autres
l'ont fait le calcul si tel était le cas
elle aurait une moins value de près de
200 euros par mois
je ne sais pas si vous vous rendez
compte ce que c'est que 200 euros par
mois pour des salaires qui sont modestes
et dans l'éducation nationale s'agissant
des obligations de service vous ne
pouvez pas ignorer que
s'agissant
deux des directeurs d'école ou des
professeurs et bien une année commence
et doit être achevée et court jusqu'à la
rentrée suivante c'est la coutume
peut-être n'y at-il pas d'assise
législatives mais ça se pratique c'est
la règle pour les rémunération et
l'obligation d'être présent donc le jour
de la pré-rentrée qui s'effectue au
début du mois de septembre
alors ça pose le problème effectivement
des remplacements
imaginez quelqu'un qui fait valoir ses
droits à la retraite qui part en mai ou
en vous pensez que on va nommer parce
que ça pose un problème de fond on va
nommer un remplaçant ou une remplaçante
pour finir l'année scolaire vous savez
est ce que vous connaissez le problème
des remplacements
moi je pourrais vous en parler plus que
cinq minutes des postes ne sont pas
remplacés je parle de mon département
qui est le département le seul de l'île
de france en expansion démographique et
où on ne fait pas les remplacements et
vous savez ce que c'est pour les parents
d'élèves et pour les élèves de ne pas
avoir de remplaçant et bien là vous êtes
en train de créer un problème qui est
spécifique certes mais qui relève de la
politique aveugle que vous que vous
faites dans l'éducation nationale mes
collègues ont parlé de la rgpp
mais on pourrait aussi parler de ce
problème qui récurrent à l'éducation
nationale et là vous allez l'aggraver
par la situation que vous allez faire
concernant les retraites je pense que ce
n'est pas un cas excuser moi c'est pas
un jeu de mots d'école c'est un cas qui
va se poser qui se pose et qui affecte
directement les pensions de retraite est
là
et les rémunérations merci chers
collègues à la parole merci monsieur le
président je donne la parole pour un
rappel au règlement mais qui va vous
faire plaisir
le préfet de paris a suspendu
l'utilisation des flashball après
l'incident de montreuil
je voudrais remercier tous les sénateurs
et autres qui sont intervenus depuis
hier sur le sujet parce que je ne peux
considérer que ça aider à la prise de
décision du préfet de paris et m'en
féliciter parce que tout le monde sait
que le flash ball est une arme
dangereuse et qu' il est vraiment est
inadaptée d'ailleurs à ce type de à tout
type de manifestation est de toute façon
dangereuse quelle que soit la situation
et ça fait très longtemps que beaucoup
se mobilisent pour interdire
l'utilisation des flashball
donc là en l'occurrence je crois que
nous avons permis que
au moins ça se le préfet prenne cette
disciple le gouvernement et par son
intermédiaire préfet parce
intermédiaires prennent cette décision
merci cher collègue monsieur bout la
parole d'option musique japonaise juste
répondre à madame briques que je crois
qu'ils aient eu dans son intervention un
peu un mélange car vous avez en même
temps parler des instituteurs des
directeurs d'école des professeurs de
collèges et ce n'est pas tout à fait sûr
les mêmes articles là nous ne sommes
plus sur les articles concernant par les
instituteurs qui effectivement sont les
seuls qu'on peut contraindre à terminer
l'année
parce qu'ils ont un régime tout à fait
particulier al'inverse des professeurs
de collèges et de lycées qui eux
prennent leur retraite au moment de
l'âge de la retraite en cours d'année
donc je voudrais pas que persister d'une
idée inexacts dans ce que nous avons
entendu c'est pas tout non mais c'est
pas tout à fait la même chose et est bon
à la limite quelle que soit la
pénibilité du travail d'instituteurs on
peut aussi remarquer que c'est le métier
en france où l'espérance de vie est la
plus longue
c'est à dire 80 l'espérance de vie est
de 88 année ce qui fait que comme le
départ est à 55 ans ça donne en général
autant de périodes de retraite que deux
périodes d'activité 33 ans
eh bien madame borvo comme à l'habitude
glousse mais ça ne change rien à la
réalité des choses bien
alors monsieur le ministre monsieur le
ministre
k
la parole est à monsieur le ministre
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît avec
avec votre autorisation si vous me
permettez je voudrais quand même tenté
de d'apporter quelques éléments de
réponses aux uns et aux autres et puis
ensuite je m'interromps près puis vous
vous laisserez reprendre vos autres
dialogue constructif riche et
intéressant je voudrais faire quelques
remarques en essayant de pardon de lire
mais ne pas rentrer quand même à mon
tour je dis à mon tour dans un jeu de
caricatures parce que c'est
malheureusement pour quelques-unes des
interventions ce que j'ai entendu
monsieur de mai elle c'est une réponse
non pas vous c'est pas vous que je vise
et c'est autre chose mais je veux dire
ce que je visais très clairement parce
que quand j'entends quelques propos je
veux dire très clairement quand je
considère que la caricature
vous avez simplement me dit monsieur
monsieur le président ce que ça se
faisait en cinq ans le passage 65 67 non
c'est en six ans monsieur le président
et on commence donc par définition 65 en
2010 est donc on va jusqu'en 2023
donc je voudrais dire que la
progressivité se fait bien à raison de
quatre mois par an ça fait donc six ans
est bien d'accord puisqu'il ya deux ans
et non pas cinq ans et en second lieu on
est en montée en puissance jusqu'en 2023
comme vous le voyez on est donc dans une
logique est à la fois très progressive
et en même temps à long terme
je le dis pour relativiser un petit peu
les inquiétudes que vous avez que vous
avez aimé évoquée je voulais vous dire
également que on est dans pour ce qui
est du cpa puisque je crois que c'est ce
que vous avez évoquées j'ai répondu
plusieurs fois pour la cessation
progressive d'activité
on est dans une logique dans ces cas là
c'est moi qui ai mal compris et je vous
répondrai dans ces cas là notre moment
mais ce que je voulais dire c'était s'il
s'agissait du cpa que j'avais déjà donné
plusieurs éléments de réponse hier pour
indiquer qu'il ne s'agissait en aucun
cas d'avoir une interruption et qu'on
prolongerait évidemment le l'activité de
telle façon qu'ils ait pas de rupture
avec la pension
quoi qu'il en soit il est hors de
question d'arriver à terme
monsieur muller voilà exactement
monsieur muller la caricature alors je
rentre même pas dans les dents les
caricatures personnel vous avez évoqué
que vous étiez élu que nous étions
coupés de je ne sais quoi du peuple tel
que vous l'avez évoqué je suis élu comme
vous monsieur je suis venu comme vous
peut-être même depuis plus longtemps que
vous je suis pas élu dans des terres qui
sont très faciles et je voulais vous
dire que je
revendique rien de plus que vous mais
j'ai le droit de vous dire que je ne
veux que vous décris rien de plus que
moi non plus quand je suis dans ma
circonscription et dans ma commune je
suis au contact de la population de la
même façon et si vous alliez la grande
gentillesse de pouvoir éviter ce type de
mises en cause personnelles même quand
elles sont exprimées avec courtoisie
vous vous rendriez service et je crois
vous feriez également débat démocratique
qui est le nôtre
une fois que je vous ai indiqué ça j'ai
quand même deux ou trois éléments précis
à vous donner
en premier lieu je voulais vous indiquez
que vous avez si je vous ai bien entendu
je crois l'avoir fait évoqué une baisse
de la masse salariale donc une baisse
des cotisations donc une difficulté
aggravé en termes de déficit
en réalité la vision vous avez du vin
sur deux alors cet égard un peu
caricatural parce qu'en réalité vous
rentrez dans un calcul fait un calcul de
court terme alors que par définition loi
sur deux est un calcul de long terme
le main sur deux monsieur le sénateur
comme vous le savez sans doute c'est une
politique est une politique qui
aujourd'hui contrairement à ce que vous
avez dit mais je pense que vous ne
l'avez dit avant toute bonne foi qui ne
génère pas les économies que vous avez
décrite en réalité le un sur deux c'est
à dire le non remplacement d'un
fonctionnaire sur deux partant à la
retraite aujourd'hui dégage
approximativement 1 milliard d'euros
d'économie par an dont 700 millions ont
été reversées sous des formes de mesures
catégorielles ans fonctionnaire
d'ailleurs pour celle des semaines les
sénateurs que ça intéresse je voudrais
préciser à ce sujet que sur les 700
millions qui ont été reversés
ils ont été en très grande partie
notamment pour l'éducation nationale
et toute la politique de mastérisation
laquelle nous procédons 200 millions
d'euros par lula pour celles ci ont été
directement issue de cette politique de
lourdement du un sur deux donc vous
voyez bien que sur le court terme nous
sommes donc dans une logique qui est une
logique plutôt de retour catégoriel que
d'économie un grain 350 millions cela
dit qu'ils ont été qui ont été dégagés
quand vous évoquez par ailleurs le gel
des salaires dans l'air gpp là encore je
ne sais pas comment vous voyez les
choses il suffit que vous relisiez par
exemple après que la cour des comptes
les remis le rapport de la cour des
comptes présidée je me permets de le
rappeler par monsieur migaud d'autres
traits duquel j'ai travaillé pendant de
très nombreuses années en tant que
membre de la commission des finances de
l'assemblée nationale que dit
aujourd'hui le rapport de monsieur
migaud il dit qu'en réalité en matière
de gel des salaires
nous devrions le faire et nous ne le
faisons pas je me permets de vous
rappeler que si vous voyez et je suis à
votre disposition pour en parler quand
vous
et l'évolution du pouvoir d'achat dans
la fonction publique dont mais il faut
bien voir les choses l'évolution du
pouvoir d'achat dans la fonction
publique qui est mesurée à partir de ce
qu'on appelle la rtp
c'est à dire en fait ce que tu gagnes un
fonctionnaire la rgpp sur une année par
rapport à l'année précédente
qu'est ce que vous constatez vous
constatez qu en réalité depuis 2000 il
n'y a pas eu une seule année où
l'augmentation du pouvoir d'achat a été
inférieure à 0,5 pas une seule y compris
de mémoire en 2003 quand il y a eu une
année blanche c'est à dire qu'il ya une
année sans augmentation du point
d'indicé dans toutes les statistiques
c'est dans tous les papiers de l'insee
dans tous les papiers de la cour des
comptes et je vous le redis il faut
connaître les chiffres dont nous
parlerons alors sur la base des chiffres
dont nous parlerons vous confondez sans
doute volontairement je pense que c'est
volontaire parce que je crois pas une
seule seconde que vous ne le sachiez pas
vous confondez ce qui relève du point
d'indicé et ce qui relève de
l'augmentation du pouvoir d'achat
quand vous prenez le point d'indicé qui
fait l'objet de discussions avec les
représentants des syndicats on constate
qu'il y a
effectivement 03 04 05 parfois 0 8%
d'augmentation c'est 0,5 pour 2010 quand
vous voyez l'augmentation globale de la
rémunération de pouvoir d'achat
vous voyez qu'en réalité c'était évident
et évidemment abondé par le gvt c'est ce
que disait le président fischer tout à
l'heure par les mesures catégorielles
par ailleurs que nous prenons au total
quand vous prenez les rémunérations dans
la fonction publique
vous prenez tous les documents vous
voulez vous verrez qu'elles sont en
augmentation et je le dis d'autant plus
volontiers que le rapport de la cour des
comptes qui a été rendu il ya quelques
jours qui prend acte du fait que pour
2010 nous avons augmenté ses
rémunérations de 0 5% et annoncé le gel
de celle ci pour 2011 le calcul qui est
fait par la cour des comptes consiste à
nous dire ce qui est vrai que nous
faisons nettement plus que tous les
autres puisque tous les autres ont
commencé par baisser et ensuite par
gelée est gelé sur plusieurs années nous
nous avons augmenté sur 2010 et nous
allons simplement sur 2011 la cour des
comptes nous dit vous devriez le faire
sur plus long terme
donc je voudrais savoir par quel mystère
quand les responsables socialistes
accèdent à des responsabilités du type
pour des comptes au fmi on a des
rapports qui disent l'un vertes ce que
disent les ténors du parti socialiste
sur les bancs de l'assemblée nationale
ou du sénat
je vous renvoie au rapport de la cour
des comptes comme monsieur woerth vous a
renvoyé au rapport du fmi concernant le
problème des retraites
concernant ensuite madame caries
je dois dire que la façon dont madame
carrie a présenté les choses étaient
assez était assez virulente aussi il ya
deux fêtes de points que je me suis
permis de noter dans son propos d'abord
c'est le fait que en matière de
convergence je n'ai pas entendu je le
redis la moindre proposition qui soit
faite par le par le parti socialiste sur
les mesures de convergence à prendre
mais surtout il est l'expression madame
que j'ai trouvé assez particulière qui
était la suivante mettre au pas les
fonctionnaires je voudrais savoir au nom
de quoi on peut porte on peut prendre
des expressions de cette nature pour
voir la politique que nous mettons en
place si madame ce qu'on se cantonne au
débat sur les retraites
je me permets de vous rappeler je vais
je me permets de vous rappeler que nous
n'avons pas aligné pour des raisons que
j'ai expliqué plusieurs fois le régime
des six derniers mois sur l'origine des
25 meilleures années et nous l'avons pas
fait parce que nous considérions que
c'était inutile de prendre cette mesure
dans la mesure où les pensions versées
le sont à peu près au même montant
c'est donc la définition précise de l'
inverse d'un dogmatisme ou d'une d'un
désir de mise au plat les régimes
spéciaux
je voulais vous dire qu'il aurait été
parfaitement légitime de s'interroger
sur le fait d'avoir une accentuation de
la montée en puissance de la réforme de
2007 2008
nous ne le faisons pas parce que nous
considérons qu'il est tout à fait normal
que les agents des régimes spéciaux et
le temps d'avoir une montée en
progression de telle qu'elle a été
définie en 2007 sans la brusquer celle
inverse madame d'une mise au pas je vous
dirais exactement la même chose pour la
politique de revenus je viens de
répondre à monsieur muller je redis
parce que j'ai indiquées celle inverse
précisément de ce qui se fait partout
ailleurs et de ce que préconisent
certains grands organismes je viens de
l'indiquer
et puis je pourrais vous dire que il ya
plein de mesures que nous ne prenons pas
dans le cas de la réforme des retraites
et qui pourtant aurait été pas
totalement illégitime
est ce que par exemple en matière de
pension de reversions est ce que pour le
minimum garantis qu'on réforme et qu'en
partie on ne pouvait pas aller plus loin
on pouvait aller plus loin pourquoi nous
ne le faisons pas parce que mesdames et
messieurs c'est exactement l'inversé ce
que vous dites
parce que nous avons de la fonction
publique et des fonctionnaires et par m
je le dis pour moi en particulier qui
travaillent sur ces questions depuis des
années et des années
j'ai un profond respect pour le service
public et pour les fonctionnaires ce qui
me permet de vous dire mais si madame
c'est pas parce que vous caricaturez les
situations pour des discours qu'on
arrive au final à avoir des polices mais
qu'on arrive au final avoir une
justification des mesures que nous
prenons
je leur dis très clairement nous n'avons
pas d'excès dans ce que nous faisons il
y en aura l'occasion de l'écrire en
d'autres
situation dans les prochains articles
qui vont arriver ne pas reprendre après
tout ce que vous avez dit mais sur la
rgpp vous la définissez comme étant
homogène sur la rgpp
vous noterez que il y à des effectifs
qui augmentent dans certains ministères
malgré tout très précisément à la
justice à la justice on a parlé des
magistrats et bien sachez le à la
justice les effectifs augmentent
il ya d'autres ministères dans
lesquelles il son style sont stabilisées
mais cela dit je redis les choses avec
clarté nous avons 5 million deux cent
mille fonctionnaires en france 5 million
deux cent mille fonctionnaires en france
cela veut dire que nous avons un taux
d'emploi de la fonction publique
rapporté la population qui est le plus
élevé qui est le plus élevé de tous les
pays et économies comparables
et d'ailleurs quand vous regardez les
effectifs dans la fonction publique de
l'état
vous constaterez que dans les dernières
années il y à une diminution sur les
deux trois dernières années des
effectifs centraux une légère
augmentation qui s'est fait dans les
organismes qui sont les organismes
rattachés c'est à dire les opérateurs
est en réalité ça stabilise à peu près
le chiffre donc par définition si vous
voulez rentrer dans un débat très
approfondie très approfondie sur les
chiffres je suis à votre entière
disposition pour le faire mais en tout
cas pas sous forme de caricature pour
monsieur fisher qui apparaît de
précarité dans la fonction publique
mais c'est vrai monsieur le président il
faut dire les choses telles qu'elles
c'est vrai qu'il ya des situations de
précarité dans la fonction publique et
c'est la raison pour laquelle le
gouvernement a décidé d'ouvrir vous le
savez un chantier qui a déjà d'ailleurs
été ouvert avec les organisations
syndicales elles mêmes
concernant par exemple les contractuels
on a une vraie situation